Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Union hat ja jetzt Sankt Pauli schön nach Hause geschickt, aber du hattest ja Taschentücher dabei.
Ach, weißt du, äh Fußball ist eigentlich auch gar nicht so wichtig.
Lokbuchen, Netzpolitik, äh, hundertsiebenundneunzig, das Einzige, was wirklich wichtig ist. Wir reden nicht über Niederlagen. Oder? Ich meine, wir reden hier eigentlich am laufenden Meter über Nieder.
Ich wollte gar nicht sagen, wenn wir hier nicht mehr über Niederlagen reden würden, dann hätten wir keinen Podcast mehr.
Erstimmt. Ja, inso.
Echt äh traurige. Ja. Sorry. Haltet die Taschentücher bereit.
Ja, sorry. Ja. Dinos war ein bisschen traurig.
Das ist alles, das ist ja alles nur ein Spiel.
Komm. Was ja, das ist ja alles. Ja, ja, ist alles nur ein Spiel. Bist ernst wird. Aber es gibt kein Spiel.
Das ist alles todernst, stimmt, es gibt kein Spiel. Na ja, also kommen wir zum kommen wir, es ist wirklich blutig ernst, es ist auch wirklich kein Spiel mehr, das war glaube ich einigen Schweizern nicht ganz klar.
Ja, wir hatten ja nun schon mehrfach darüber berichtet, dass nach äh dem es schon einige parlamentarische Entscheidungen gab, dieses Überwachungsgesetz, das Büpf in der Schweiz, äh, dann nochmal von einer ähm,
von einer Volksabstimmung, wie heißt das in der Schweiz? Weiß es so.
Wie ähm Herr Referendum.
Referendum. Genau, das war's. Von einem Referendum noch hätte gestoppt werden können, Kraft,
der Gewalt des Volkes, aber äh das Volk war offenbar anderer Meinung, also zumindest die Leute, die zur Wahl gegangen sind, weiß nicht, ob da irgendwas über Wahlbeteiligung noch mit vermerkt war, die ist ja,
auch nicht unbedingt immer so überwältigend, aber dafür halt oft. Und wie viel waren's? Zwei Drittel waren der Meinung,
Ne, passt schon. Hauptsache äh Sicherheit und dann ist er da auch noch der Cyber und so und das ist ja alles total gefährlich und da müssen wir jetzt mal unbedingt was gegen tun. Ja und jetzt äh,
die Schweiz aus,
Unserer Sicht natürlich etwas doof da, dass es sich jetzt ein gesetztes Paket eingefangen hat, was umfangreiche Überwachungsmaßnahmen legitimiert in der Schweiz und über die Schweiz hinaus und äh ja, das ist eigentlich gar nicht mehr lustig.
Nee, was haben wir da? Also an dieser Stelle sei Lokbuchnetzpolitik Ausgabe einhundertfünfundachtzig nochmal empfohlen, wo Kiere da sehr viel drüber erzählt hat,
Und äh jetzt am schönsten finde ich ein oder einen der schönsten Passen, was ist eigentlich der die Mehrzahl von Passus.
Eine gute Frage.
Gesetz wahrscheinlich. Ähm äh Provider müssen die Daten an das Zentrum für elektronische Operationen liefern. Und das ist der Armee angegliedert. Also,
Diese Datensammlung,
irgendwie direkt bei der Armee aufzuhängen. In Deutschland geht's ja ums Outsourcen, da kommen wir nachher nochmal zu. Also das ist wirklich ein relativ krasses Gesetz, ne. Wenn man in einer, in der Zeit des Notens, bei einem Referendum,
dass sich dagegen wendet, sich so eine sich so ein Ergebnis einzuholen. Ist schon krass.
Ja, aber was äh haben wir erwartet? Also, meine, das ist halt einfach das Problem, dass die Öffentlichkeit ähm an der Stelle einfach mit Angst geleitet wird und von daher relativ.
Uninformiert, glaube ich, auch über solche Sachen abstimmt und letzten Endes überhaupt nicht schneit, was Sache ist, ist halt immer noch das das alte Lied von äh nichts zu verbergen haben, aber das ist natürlich,
Quatsch, man es geht nicht dadrum, um irgendwas zu verbergen hat, sondern ob man,
sprechende Verteidigungsmittel gegen ein Staatssystem hat und in dem Moment wo man den Staatssystem einfach uneingeschränkte Überwachungs
ähm Möglichkeiten gibt, die eben auch ins Private reingeht, dann muss man sich eben auch über einen potenziellen Missbrauch nicht wundern. Das ist das alte Lied,
Aber das ist jetzt sozusagen vorbei. Da können wir jetzt nichts mehr dran drehen und so wird das jetzt wahrscheinlich kommen.
Und in Deutschland ja auch.
Da sind wir noch nicht ganz so weit, glaube ich, ne.
Wir hatten welche das war eine der Folgen bei denen ich nicht da war äh.
Der letzten Zeit.
In der letzten Zeit wird das BNE Gesetz mal ausführlich hier besprochen wurde. Auch diese Folge sei an der Stelle nochmal empfohlen.
Nummer hundertvierundneunzig, die ich mit Andre Meister gemacht habe.
Und dieses dieses Gesetz da gab es jetzt dann die Anhörung der im Innenausschuss mit einer ganzen Reihe an äh,
An Sachverständigen Andrea Vosshof die äh,
ähm Daten Bundesbeauftragte für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit war da, dann äh der Professor Doktor Matthias Becker vom Karlsruher Institut für Technologie. Waren relativ viele Leute da eingeladen. Insgesamt glaub
zwölf, dreizehn Leute,
Und da war jetzt irgendwie äh keiner wirklich dabei, der sagte, das ist äh der jetzt da großartig applaudierte. Allerdings
hat es sich ja so ein bisschen eingebürgert bei diesen Bundestagsanhörungen. Auch diejenigen anzuhören, die betroffen werden. Äh zum Beispiel ähm
in diesem Fall den Gerhard Schindler vom Bundesnachrichtendienst, der dann äh sagt, äh ja finde ich total toll, was hier äh was hier passiert und ähm,
die Zielsetzung dieses Gesetzes ist begrüßt zu begrüßen besonders bedeutsam für den Arbeitsalltag ist die Präzision und die Schaffung von speziellen Rechtsgrundlagen für die Auslandauslandfernmeldeaufklärung
Für die Erfassung von Verkehrsdaten, Kooperationen mit ausländischen öffentlichen Stellen,
automatische Datenübermittlung bei diesen Kooperationen, ja? Also ich finde der gut, ja? Das äh der hat sich da richtig gefreut.
Da sollte man auch stutzig werden, wenn äh die Geheimdienste irgendwas total abfeiern.
Ja, das ist wirklich äh ja,
sehr, sehr, sehr beunruhigend, was da passiert und ich weiß da auch gar nicht mehr viel zu zu sagen, ne. Es gibt irgendwie ähm weit aus,
Ausdefinierte Überwachungszwecke hier. Dann gibt's ja noch die eine Sache ist ja der, diese Idee mit dem mit der Kontrolle,
irgendwie auch unklar ist, was das hier, was was das sein soll, wo jetzt auch irgendwie schon,
vorgehaltener Hand diskutiert wurde, ob jetzt irgendwie jemand vom Geheimdienst, denn nachher in dieses Kontrollgremium wechseln soll oder auch denkst du, das ist doch alles wieder so ein Quatsch, ja,
Und ähm.
Ja, also überhaupt ist es ist schon mal problematisch, ein Kontrollgremium zu schaffen, was im Prinzip der Bundesregierung untersteht,
Also ich meine welches welches Maß an Kontrolle kann man sich von so einem Gremium,
Versprechen halt kein nennenswertes, weil an der Stelle halt noch nicht mal mehr das Parlament in irgendeiner Form involviert ist. Das ja nun wirklich den Auftrag hätte, Transparenz herzustellen, aber die ist natürlich innerhalb des Kanzleramtes überhaupt nicht,
durchsetzbar,
Plus zusätzlich der Tendenz, dass eben genau solche Kontrollgruppen äh dann eben auch noch mit Ex-Geheimdienstlern ähm besetzt werden. Also, dass es dann einfach nur noch albern.
Und auch nicht unbedingt so verfassungsgemäß würde ich sagen.
Die Opposition.
Spricht schon von Karlsruhe, also Andre Hahn, von den von der Linken. Äh Chris Han-Christian Ströbele, von den Grünen haben schon gesagt, ja, also sehen, sehen wir dann in Karlsruhe wieder. Andre Hahn hat also auch gesagt, so,
wenn.
Man jetzt ein verfassungswidriges Gesetz beschließt, was dann ein paar Jahre angewendet wird, bis es wieder in von Karlsruhe kassiert wird, bis eine Politik, die er verantwortungslos findet und äh das,
unverantwortlich findet, ähm das sehe ich auch so. Ja schon echt ein immer wiederkehrender, sehr unschöner.
Ähm ein sehr unschönes Muster, das solche Gesetze quasi,
wissentlich so geschrieben werden, dass sie am Ende dann nochmal von Karlsruhe gestutzt werden, damit man weiß, dass das Ergebnis danach auf jeden Fall das Maximum ist, ne,
Lass uns auf jeden Fall übers Ziel hinaus schießen äh und dann können die Verfassungsrichter schon schön die Grenzen genauso schneiden, dass wir nichts ausgelassen haben äh.
Um um den Weg nach Karlsruhe zu zu vergessen. Man könnte quasi sagen, Karlsruhe ist sowas wie das willst, du willst eigentlich, dass dein äh Gesetz dahin geschickt wird,
damit du,
Auf jeden Fall das maximal Mögliche rausholst. Könntest sagen, ein ein Sicherheitsgesetz, was nicht von irgendjemandem nach Karlsruhe geschleppt wird und da nochmal zurechtgeschnitten wird, ist quasi schlecht, weil.
Da kommt dann gleich die passende Lobby-Gruppe und fragt, was was denn hier los, kein, kein, kein Karlsruher.
Hast du nicht performt? Ja, der, es ist offensichtlich mehr rauszuholen gewesen, ne? Also so wie wie bei wenn deine, wenn du bei Gehaltsverhandlungen, deine Gehaltsvorstellungen sagst und wir einfach nur gesagt wird, ja, alles klar, dann weißt du.
Scheiße.
Es könnte sein, dass ich mehr hätte kriegen können, ne? Also du möchtest ja, also das Optimum ist ja, du sagst irgendwie einen Betrag und dann sagen die, nein, wir können dir allenfalls so und so viel geben, dann weißt du, okay, du hast wenigstens das Maximum rausgeholt, ne
und so diese so so funktioniert Sicherheitsgesetzgebung ähm im im dritten Millennium, ne,
Wenn das nicht irgendwie nochmal von Karlsruhe zurechtgeschnitten wurde, dann hast du offenbar Underperformt, ja.
Ja, da kommt dann so, kommt dann die die Herren in den dunklen Anzügen in den Raum und sagen, Verfassungskonform? Verfassungskonform.
Verfassungskonform im ersten Anlauf? Was ist das denn.
Also wirklich, wir müssen reden. Roset Film.
So funktioniert das, oder?
Tschau. Tja.
Es gab da noch einige äh Gegenaktionen, also wie die diese Online-Petition hatten wir ja letzte Mal schon im äh drauf hingewiesen, auch auf die Kundgebung,
Die war dann, na ja, es war ja Montagmorgen äh mit vierzig bis achtzig Leute, wurde glaube ich kolportiert, besucht. Das ist natürlich ähm zahlenmäßig jetzt nicht so irre viel.
Aber es ist eben auch ein Montag und dann muss er erstmal genug Leute finden, die sich die das kurzfristig mit ihrem Berufsalltag verbinden können, äh dorthin zu gehen.
Ja gut, aber es wurde ja dann den äh Parlamentsangehörigen Bundestagsabgeordneten noch Medizin gereicht,
von der Digitalcourage äh in Form des neuartigen Produktes, wie heißt das? BND, AL.
Ich weiß es nicht, der BND, ich weiß leider nicht genau, wie man das ausspricht, der das äh Wortspiel,
Er schließt sich mir nicht BND-Alforte, BND, Forte, BND, Alphorte, ein Medikament äh bei akutem äh Machtdefizit. Es ist zustimmungspflichtig
Das ist sehr schöne Wortspiele dabei. Ist halt so eine Medikamentenbüchse. So eine Medikamentendose mit äh äh ich glaube ähm die ich habe die jetzt mal nicht genommen. Ich war mir nicht so sicher,
Das riecht aber nach Pfefferminzbonbons, die da drin sind.
Ähm wir hatten einen ganz schönen Beiparkzell, den wir hier auch äh verlinken.
Nebenwirkungen in bereits in kleinen Dosen äh.
Für Freiheit und Menschenrechte. Giftig, giftig für Freiheit und.
Und Menschenrech.
Ja na ja. Finde ich, finde ich aber auch ganz lustig so mal ne, eben.
Einfach mal andere Sachen zu gehen, andere Wege zu gehen, ne? Am Ende ist das auch nur ein äh ein Flyer, wo drauf steht, wir sind dagegen, aber er ist halt lustiger gemacht, ne. Es ist halt ein
Ein schönes Produkt, was da mit dabei ist und ähm,
Placebo gegen den Terror. Das ist schon äh ist einfach mal ganz nett. Da muss man muss da eben jetzt auch kreativer werden und das ist da geschehen, finde ich super.
Haben sie viele von verschickt.
Ja, passt aber wahrscheinlich bei den meisten Leuten nicht in den Briefkasten.
Ich musste leider auch äh das bei der Post abholen. Macht sowas bitte nicht nochmal. Ich habe kriege immer Angst. Was hast du einen Brief im, also erwartest nix, hast einen Zettel im Briefkasten? Geh mal zur Post, du musst dir was abholen, denkst du, einschreiben, Scheiße, neben dem,
die mir Führerschein weg jetzt oder haben sie, jetzt haben sie mich endlich, jetzt kriegen sie mich doch so, ne? Und äh dann dann,
dass es nur äh Gift war.
Die Auguen sagen, Herr Herr Neumann, sie müssen ihre Medizin nehm.
Drei Skittels stellen sie sich vor. Na ja.
Bleiben wir beim BND.
Bleiben wir beim DBND, ja? Ähm ein eine sehr interessante Veröffentlichung.
Und zwar gibt es eine Firma mit dem Namen,
Net Bots, die heißt glaube ich inzwischen nicht mehr Netbots, die heißt, sondern wurde gekauft von einer von einem anderen Unternehmen. Also diesen Zeitpunkt hieß dieses Unternehmen noch und die verkaufen
Überwachungssysteme
also Raum, Sicherheitssysteme, du würdest äh quasi von denen könntest du eine Überwachungskamera kaufen, die äh haben aber die deren Systeme haben zum Beispiel dann auch irgendwie Rauchdetektoren und Temperaturdelektoren drin, das bringst du zum Beispiel ganz gerne mal in einem Rechenzentrum an
Quasi die Kontrolle darüber zu einem Hochsicherheitsrechenzentrum, um zuerst zu sehen, dass da keiner reinmarschiert. Zweitens eben ist ja Feuer in einem Rechenzentrum immer eine eine der großen Sorgen und so, also wirklich.
Hochsicherheitsbereich äh Überwachungssysteme, unter anderem auch mit Video, aber auch anderen Dingen, ne?
Denn wir wissen ja, Videotechnik ist schafft Sicherheit. Wir brauchen mehr Videotechnik. Mhm. Herr Henkel. Herr Henkel.
Wir brauchen mehr Videotechnik. Herr Henkel, ja ähm.
Könnt ihr mal im Serverraum tätig werden, Herr Henkel.
Genau, so und jetzt gibt's diese diese äh diese Videotechnik.
Darüber wurde jetzt BND vor mehr als zehn Jahren,
informiert, dass diese von den USA verkaufte Videotechnik geback dort ist. Also diese Geräte haben über das die kommen ja dann ans Netz, ne? So dann ist ja alles hier das ist ja, ne? Äh IOT ist das ja.
Internet auf Dingsbums.
Und ähm dass die Funken also nach Hause, die haben eine Verbindung in die USA hergestellt, die nicht dokumentiert war und darüber offenbar eine Backdoor gehabt, ne? Und darüber wurde der wurde der BND von einer Quelle von einem anonymen Hinweis in Kenntnis gesetzt,
Und der, was man ja eigentlich vermuten würde, ist, dass der BND dann der dem Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz Bescheid sagt, da dieses Jahr zuständig ist für die Spionageabwehr.
Und äh sagt hier, passt auf, sorgt dafür, dass wir diese Geräte nicht äh benutzen äh sorgt dafür, dass die Gefire Award werden, sorgt dafür, ne? Also eigentlich,
die musst du ja solche Geräte musst du ja dann einfach gar nicht erst in Betrieb nehmen. Ne, das ist ja ganz klar, dass das nicht geht. Und äh das hätte man also tun müssen,
Ne, der BND hat sich gedacht, na das wäre aber schon ärgerlich, wenn das jetzt politische Implikationen bekommen würde,
ne? Und dass wir jetzt irgendwie den Vertrieb dieser Geräte irgendwie behindern. Das wäre ja das, da wären unsere amerikanischen Freunde sicherlich überhaupt nicht glücklich drüber.
Deswegen machen wir das mal nicht. Und wurde nicht getan.
Zehn Jahre lang weiterverkauft, BND wusste das, Back dort drin, alles super.
Also Bactors in Videokameras finde ich ja jetzt auch nochmal besonders perfide. Also so
Also nicht das andere Backdoor ist jetzt deutlich äh äh weniger perfide Veren aber so Kameras, da kurven sich die Leute sozusagen Überwachungsequipment und das ist,
Ist schon da sozusagen direkt der Zugang drin. Ich meine, was natürlich auch sehr naheliegend ist für eine potenzielle Angriffsszenario, dass man sich sozusagen genau in das Sicherheitsequipment selber rein äh hängt, was eigentlich irgendwie Angriffe verhindern soll, dass also
das.
Noch dazu, du musst ja dann, also das geht ja noch weiter, du musst ja du musst ja dann noch dafür sorgen, dass die Leute das kaufen und das haben sie erreicht durch Konkurrenzlose Preise.
Ah, die haben sie aber auch billig.
Ja klar. Das ist doch genauso wie ähm also das sind klassische klassische Strategie. Ähm.
Es war jetzt, also es gibt auch ein, jetzt fällt mir der Name des Unternehmens nicht ein,
für die Abrechnung, für die Abrechnung im Telekommunikationsmarkt, das ist relativ kompliziert. Ähm, also so ein Telefonnetz funktioniert irgendwie vor sich hin und muss halt dann irgendwie eine sehr komplexe unterschiedliche Verträge mit den einzelnen,
Leuten, die haben ein Volumenkontingent, der eine zahlt zwanzig Cent für eine SMS der anderen neunzehn. Und das ist relativ schwierig aus dem,
oder nicht nicht unbedingt trivial aus deinem funktionierenden,
Telefonnetz, dann eine äh eine ein Rechnungssystem zu machen. Ein Abrechnungssystem. Und äh das gibt's natürlich dann auch als äh sehr, sehr kostengünstigen Dienstleister,
sagt, also übrigens einfach die ganzen Kommunikationslogs von all deinen Kunden,
und deine Kundendaten und die Verträge, die du mit den Kunden hast und wir machen dir fertige Rechnungen dadraus und dann musst du nur noch auf dem Konto gucken, ob das Geld da ist,
Es ist eine Dienstleistung, die gerne von unseren ich glaube israelischen Freunden angeboten wird.
Auch das hätte natürlich auch politische Implikationen,
wenn man da jetzt äh was Böses vermuten würde. Aber so, so kommen die, so kommst du an Daten. Das ist eine klassische Möglichkeit natürlich, ne? Also als Dienstleistung anbieten, als Produkt anbieten und halt so billig machen, dass sie's alle kaufen.
Aber der Skandal an dieser Stelle ist nicht, dass sie das getan haben. Der Skandal ist, dass der BND zehn Jahre lang davon wusste und die das den Verkauf dieser Produkte in Deutschland toleriert hat.
Was durch nichts zu entschuldigen ist. Erst recht nicht durch die Befürchtung möglicher politischer Implikationen,
Wenn man sich gegen so eine Bekoor äh wehrt, die die unsere Freunde äh in unsere Hochsicherheitstrakte verkaufen. Also das, ich meine, das ist das ist richtig beängstigend, erbärmlich, ne?
Und und halt wirklich zehn Jahre lang in Security bei Design, mit Wissen unseres Auslandsgeheimdienstes in Deutschland verkauft.
Noch problematischer wird's natürlich, wenn äh also ich weiß nicht, ob davon jetzt hier irgendwas irgendwie die Rede war, aber äh wenn das BSI so handeln würde, zum Beispiel, was ja explizit für den Schutz äh der Bürger und Unternehmen auch äh angetreten ist, als
das stelle ich jetzt hier nicht, dass sie das wussten. Nur meiner Meinung nach sollte das eben nicht auf einzelne Behörden beschränkt sein, sondern im Prinzip müssen eigentlich,
jeglicher Teil des Staates äh entsprechende Meldepflichten haben und natürlich auch der BND,
Aber machen sie halt nicht. Was übrigens so die äh Sicherheit von.
Videokameras und Überwachungskameras betrifft da noch einen schönen Twitter-Account Tipp. FFD acht, FFD,
als der Account und da läuft irgendwie soweit ich weiß,
irgend so ein Skript, was irgendwie die ganze Zeit äh im Internet herumstochert und irgendwie so automatisch äh einfach offene Ports, offene, schlecht geschützte Überwachungskameras mit Internetzugang irgendwie abgrast
sich Bilder runterlädt und die dann einfach postet. Äh mit etwas äh absurden Beschreibung,
teilweise belanglos, leere Straßen, alles Mögliche immer wieder aber auch mal
ganz interessante äh äh Einblicke dabei, was sozusagen auf einmal alles sicher wird, weil es ja dann potentiell auch, was weiß ich, Hinterhöfe von irgendwelchen
Häusern oder Gärten sind, die ja nun explizit eben nicht betreten werden sollen, aber dann eben wunderbar äh sichtbar sind.
Vorlesungsseif von so einer Uni,
alle von hinten den Monitor fotografiert.
Äh ja genau.
Oh man. Oh Mann. Ja, da gibt's ja also ich weiß da gibt es ähm auch sehr schöne Suchmaschinen im Internet,
wenn man da äh gelangweilt ist, kann man da dann einfach sagen, ich würde mal gerne, ich würde mal gerne eine Kamera sehen äh und äh dann kann man das Häkchen setzen
muss das die Ford Passwort haben und dann kann man sich das eben noch nach Ländern anschauen,
Das ist äh sehr, sehr übel, was dieses dieses dieses Internet auf Pfingst äh Scherze ähm gerade mit diesen Kameras, das ist wirklich ein Alptraum.
Fällt mir auch gerade ein, falls irgendjemand noch eine schöne Deko-Idee für den Kongress braucht, äh ladet doch mal diese Bilder von diesem Twitter-Account runter. Das macht einfach eine geile Posterwall. Oder? Um so eine Wand einfach nur vollkleben mit diesen äh.
Naja oder du gehst du, du gehst halt einfach auf diese Kameras und streamst überall hin, ne? Ist jetzt auch kein Problem, äh nee, ich meine, das sind die machen in der Regel Video-Feeds, ne. Das ist jetzt irgendwie also das.
Ja gut, das wäre auch nochmal ganz nett, aber so einfach so als als Kunstaspekt äh fände ich einfach hier eine Ausnutzung dieser Bilderflut, die er hier irgendwie auch äh irgendwie auch sehr homogen sind in ihrer Heterogenität,
Schon geil, eine überwachte Welt. Na gut.
Also äh wir rocken mit dem Finger und sagen du böser BND, so geht's ja nicht.
Nee, so geht's wirklich nicht. Also das ist, das ist beängstigend, peinlich. Und und richtig richtig überlegt mal über zehn Jahre, ne.
Tja, sowas würde die NSA ja nie machen.
Das tut uns leid, dass sie äh zehn Jahre lang von der NSA beim Kacken gefilmt wurden, aber wenn wir äh uns dagegen gewehrt hätten, dann hätte das politische Implikation gehabt.
Das verstehen sie doch sicherlich.
Sicherlich.
Sind doch unsere Freunde. Unsere Freunde, die NSA hat's aber auch gut gemacht,
Es gab ja die lange Diskussion darüber äh oder die lange Spekulation darüber, woher kamen diese NSA-Tools, die veröffentlicht wurden vor? Wie lange ist das jetzt hier ein, zwei Monate, ne? Ähm.
Wo also eine Hackergruppe eine,
mutmaßliche Hackergruppe gesagt hat, hier wir haben die NSA gehackt und wir veröffentlichen jetzt mal deren Tools. Ähm wo auch mehrere Zero Days dabei waren, die eben öffentlich noch nicht bekannt waren, wo Cisco dann Backdoors in den Routan fixen musste. Also richtig üble,
Spielzeug.
Und und genau, also mutmaßlich so ein Teil also nahe von dieser Telet Excess äh Group oder Organisation Tar, Taro hieß,
ne? Ähm die halten, ne, die sozusagen gezielter Angriffe macht, indem sie bestimmte Geräte äh vorher oder später dann auch äh infiziert.
Und was mich daran ja wunderte, war, also es waren Haltbisch-Erklärungen dabei, wie die Tools anzuwenden sind
Ne, also es waren es waren nicht nur die die Skripte oder die Binaries selber, sondern es war auch
hier diese Argumente musst du dazugeben und es du musst vorher scannen, ob das auch diese Firmwareversion vom Cisco Router ist oder so,
Und das lässt du ja üblicherweise nicht irgendwo liegen, das hast du halt auf deinem Rechner, mit dem du angreifst, deswegen halte ich das nach wie vor für,
Eher mittelwahrscheinlich, dass die ähm.
Beziehungsweise im Idealfall noch nicht mal auf dem Rechner, mit dem man angreift, sondern einem Rechner mit dem Mann, ja, äh, am besten mit gar nichts verbunden ist.
Die gehen aber jetzt davon aus, dass äh.
Sie schließen eigentlich aus, dass es einen Whisleblower gab und sie gehen davon aus, dass diese Software auf einem,
Angriffsrechner irgendwo äh vergessen wurde.
Also, dass irgendjemand halt unvorsichtig war, ne? Keine Ahnung, eine Kiste geohnt hat und seine Tutorials, seine Hacking-Tutorials irgendwie da draufgeladen hat. Das ist irgendwie die Geschichte, die sie jetzt versuchen zu erzählen.
Nicht ein Angriffsrechner, sondern angegriffener Rechner. Meinst du.
Ein angegriffener Rechner, den er dann wahrscheinlich weiter benutzt hat,
Also du machst das ja selten oder bei dieser Art von Angriffen bist du jetzt selten, dass du irgendwie direkt dein Ziel kriegst, sondern du, was weiß ich, du musst halt erstmal irgendwie,
in das Netz selber reinkommen, dann musst du aus dem Netz irgendwie Angriffe auf weitere Komponenten durchführen oder auf andere Mitarbeiter oder so,
Und hier gehen sie davon aus, dass jemand,
Die Software vergessen habe und quasi vielleicht so auf seinem ersten Hobb dann einfach mal seinen Angreifer, also sein Angriffsasenal auf einen Rechner geworfen hat
den er eben als Haupt benutzt hat oder was auch immer, also die die Geschichte, die sie jetzt hier erzählen ist, wurde irgendwo vergessen und ist so in die falschen Hände, wahrscheinlich der Russen geraten,
So halte ich nach wie vor für irgendwie so ein bisschen,
Also kann gut sein, was waren eben diese Erklärungen mit dabei, die sollten da eigentlich nicht sein, das wäre schon enorm fahrlässig, von wem auch immer, wer sie da vergessen haben soll, will. Aber kann sein.
Das ist jetzt zumindest die aktuelle Gerüchtelage im Nachrichtenwald, wie das äh gelaufen sein kann, wissen wir nicht.
Die Idee wäre nur, dass man hier, dass dass dann geschrieben wird, die NSA habe den Verlust dieser Software entdeckt,
und hat dann versucht herauszufinden, ob jemand anderes diese Tools benutzt,
Das heißt, die wussten einfach so, ah okay, jemand andere Menschen haben Kenntnis von unseren Zero Days? Dann gucken wir jetzt mal, ob diese Angriffe, die wir gegen andere machen, irgendwo bei uns auch stattfinden,
Kannst ja dann nach Monitoren, wenn du den äh wenn du weißt, wie der Angriff funktioniert, dann kannst du darauf,
wenn du ein Monitoringsystem hast, kannst du darauf Monitoren. Das haben sie gemacht und haben festgestellt, och ja, nee, benutzt keiner,
Ähm deswegen fühlen wir uns jetzt auch nicht verpflichtet, die Hersteller zu informieren, weil dann werden ja auch unsere Zero-Days weg. Die brauchen wir ja noch,
Das heißt auch hier wieder
Ein Geheimdienst hat Kenntnis davon, dass es erstens diese Sicherheitslücken gibt, die er selber ausnutzt, hat weiterhin Kenntnis davon, dass andere diese konkreten Angriffstools und Sicherheitslücken auch kennen.
Und informiert aber nicht,
die äh die Hersteller. Weil Herr NSA jetzt hier anrufen können, hätte sagen können. Hm, ja, es gibt da irgendwie so russische Hacker, die explodieren eure Geräte so, so macht die mal, macht mal die die Sicherheitslücken weg.
Wobei die Betroffenen Hersteller jetzt in diesem Fall sicherlich schon Wind von der Sache bekommen haben.
Nein. Das ist ja spezifisch,
Dass sie sagen, wir haben uns nicht ähm verpflichtet gefühlt, dem Bescheid zu sagen. Und die Fixes für die für die für die Win-Rebilities kamen ein oder zwei Tage nach der Veröffentlichung durch die Shello Brokers.
Ja, also jetzt ist die Jesus die News rum, aber ach so, okay.
Sehr viel früher. Die NSA wusste, dass sehr viel früher.
Ja ist klar. Das war das, was du meinst. Tja.
Man redet, die Rede ist hier von drei Jahre.
Drei Jahre lang wussten die, dass sie, dass sie ihr Cyberwaffenarsenal äh oder Teile ihres Cyber-Waffenasinals an irgendjemanden verloren haben und haben nicht dazu darauf hingewirkt, dass diese Sicherheitslücken wegkommen.
Ich sage dir eins, Tim, der Sicherheitsaspekt von Cyber ist sehr, sehr schwer und vielleicht sogar unmöglich. Ehrlich.
Echt? Das kann man da schon.
Ausschwärmen.
Ja, schwärmen wir aus. Oh Mann.
Schweren wir aus zum Bundesverband der Zeitungsverleger oder Bund der Zeitungsverleger, der einen Kongress abgefeiert hat und sich da einen coolen Speaker engagiert hat, der mal so ein bisschen was erzählt.
Lieblingspolitiker.
Was wir da so äh war da niemand geringeres als Günther Öttinger.
Ja. Soll ich mal? Ja, mache ich.
Jetzt könntest du P drücken und dein Napo essen.
Die Sätze sind ein bisschen lang und das entscheidende Wort äh ist in diesem Ausschnitt nicht drin. Das entscheidende Wort, über das er hier redet, ist Leistungsschutzrecht.
Genau, darum ging's nämlich in seiner Rede und äh ja im Prinzip kann man diese ganze Rede als so eine Art,
was sie verzweiflungstat wäre wahrscheinlich äh nicht das richtige Wort. Der hals die Leute da so richtig ein für eine,
politische Maßnahme einzutreten, für die er offenbar in einer kritischen Zielgruppe, nämlich in diesem Fall den Onlinern keine Unterstützung sieht,
Meint aber, es wäre jetzt sozusagen äh an der Zeit für diese Printverleger, doch für ihre eigenen Interessen mal einzustehen, indem sie Druck auf quasi ihre eigenen,
Journalisten machen sollen, äh doch hier bitte mal die Meinung, äh dieses Politikers anzunehmen. Also, wo leben wir denn?
Nichtzensur, Nichtzensur, aber Meinungen, Überzeugungen, Argumente. Na, der sagt, das ist, das muss man sich.
Tourdemokratisch.
Er fordert die Verleger.
Gesagt.
Nee, ich meine, er fängt ja schon an, es ist ja, es ist.
Der hat's was gesagt.
Er fängt ja an mit dem.
Mit dem Begriff. Ähm bei allem, was es so an Pressefreiheit gibt, äh müssen wir ja aber doch mal,
Bei allem, was Redaktionsstatut und Redaktionsfreiheit besteht, müssen, mache ich mir trotzdem so ein bisschen Sorge über die Reaktion,
Die Tageszeitung Print war sehr gut. Besten Dank auch für ihre Stellungnahme. Die war klar. Ja. Also der geht ernsthaft hin und sagt, ich habe hier einen Gesetzesvorschlag oder einen einen V-Ordnungsvorschlag von dieser Kommission.
Die, die der betrifft, die Onliner, ne, die die Print-Tageszeitungen haben ja mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht nichts zu tun.
Nicht in der Schule auch, aber die sind ja nicht so von betroffen.
Die, die es wirklich betrifft, nämlich die Online-Redaktion, die waren davon nicht überzeugt. Jetzt müsst ihr die nicht nicht gleich zensieren, aber ihr solltet schon mal mit denen reden.
Argumen.
Kulturell demokratische Zukunft das Recht hatte benutzt,
Ähm und dann sagte schwärmt aus, redet mit euren Angestellten über die Ausgewogenheit, die ihr die Ausgewogenheit des Level Playing fielt, dass ihr für eure Arbeit von morgen braucht.
Liebe Verleger, redet mit euren Journalisten, sorgt dafür, dass sie die Leistungsschutzrecht positiv bewerten.
Auf Lineus, auf Linie.
Das mache ich ja für euch, um euren Markt zu retten.
Das waren jetzt mehrere Passos. Plural ist nämlich Passus von Passus.
Ob ich's nachgeschaut. Aber man kann auch Absätze sagen, das läuft dann irgendwie aufs Gleiche raus. Ah, okay. Ja. Versteht dann auch. Versteht dann auch jemand.
Passanten.
Also der Typ, der redet ja wirklich in einem kryptischen Code. Was meint denn der bitte.
Was meint denn der da bitte? Dann, wenn sie, das und das nicht tun, dann haben sie ein Zeitfenster für ihre ökonomische und damit kulturell, demokratische Zukunft versäumen,
Also ihre ökonomische Zukunft.
Na ja, also.
Wirtschaftliches Überleben.
Seine tatsächliche Idee ist ja, äh oder die Idee dieses Leistungsschutzrechtes ist ja äh es gibt den Google, der Google äh hat das ganze Geld im Internet und der Google fielt,
den Verlagen ihre Inhalte,
und veröffentlicht die an anderer Stelle mit den Anreißertexten und
Das müssen wir unterbinden. Wir müssen irgendwie von dem Google Geld ab abzwacken. Und dann ist ja das
Das Problem mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht ist ja, dass dann der Google eben gesagt hat, ach so, ihr wollt gar nicht, wir sollen nicht auf euch verlinken, das ist ja okay. Sag das doch, ist doch gar kein Thema. Äh machen wir klar. Und dann ähm.
Weil sie ja eben so, oh nein, jetzt bricht, jetzt liest keiner mehr unsere scheiß Seiten. Ähm auch das wollen wir ja auch nicht.
War der ganze Hühnerhof so richtig in Alarmst.
Und dann haben sie am Ende alle dem Google mehr oder weniger gesagt, okay, wir wir geben dir, wir treten alle Leistungs äh Schutzrecht Ansprüche ab.
Aber nur dem Google.
Hauptsache du verlinkst wieder auf uns. So, so ist die Realität, aber was sich was sich dahinter verbirgt, ist, natürlich geht es den Online äh Redaktionen schlecht. Es ist.
Finde ich nach wie vor verwunderlich, dass sie das teilweise seit so vielen Jahren machen. Ich glaube, Spiegel One hat jetzt kürzlich zwanzigstes gefeiert. Ähm.
Das ist diese ganze Geschichte mit dem Journalismus ist teuer. Ähm es gibt keine,
nennenswerten tragbaren Finanzierungsmodelle und das da gehe ich sogar mit, dass das eine große Gefahr so für die Zukunft ist, die wir zeitnah lösen müssen. Sonst werden die zumachen.
Also entweder ihre Seiten oder ihre gesamte, ihre gesamten Gebäude, ihr gesamtes Unternehmen. Was sie jetzt machen,
Die Strategie, die sie jetzt gerade machen, sind ja so diese Plus-Inhalte, ne? Sitzt das passiert andauernd, dass jetzt auf einen Artikel klickst und dann steht irgendwie SZ plus oder Spiegel, haste nicht gesehen dran und dann darfst du nicht mehr weiterlesen, musst du bezahlen,
ist ein Modell,
Leistungsschutzrecht soll das lösen und er redet ja, also Öttingers Plan ist ja ganz klar zu sagen, na ja okay, mit einzelnen Ländern machen sie das bei einzelnen Ländern macht er Google uns Ärger, aber wenn wir das erste Mal auf dem europäischen Markt haben.
Dann dann können wir dem können wir dem paar paar Millionen abpressen.
Na, er hat sich ja dann diesmal nicht nur im Rahmen von äh Vorträgen auf äh von Lobbygruppen äh ausgelassen, sondern
interessanterweise hat er sich auch in eine Twitter-Diskussion verstricken lassen. Ich glaube ausgehend von einem Kommentar von Mario Sixtus,
Also es war zumindest ein bisschen meine Wahrnehmung, dass es damit irgendwie angefangen hat. Der sozusagen die die Absurdität dieses äh äh Gesetzes nochmal schön,
dargestellt hat, Göttinger, äh Öttinger dann offenbar selbst twitternd, also weiß ich, vielleicht gibt's ja auch Team Öttinger. Ähm davon macht er so ganz den Eindruck, verwies halt auf irgendwelche Studien,
Ähm,
Das ist ja alles ganz schlimm sei, weil ja äh fünfundvierzig Prozent oder so äh ja dann überhaupt nach dem Anreißer äh äh nicht auf den eigentlichen Artikel äh klicken würden,
Und das sei ja dann nun ein ein Beleg dafür, dass er hier sozusagen Value äh kostenlos mitgenommen wird und so weiter.
Das ist das ist auf so vielen Ebenen falsch. Äh eine der schönsten Antworten dazu war,
Krass, das heißt ja, dass immer noch dreiundfünfzig Prozent klicken und so eine Conversion Rate kriegst du ja nirgendwo, ja? Also es ist halt der, der hat diese Zahl einfach überhaupt nicht verstanden, ja? Und ähm.
Was er bei Netzkritik Ork hat, dann wurde es nochmal genauer auseinandergenommen in dieser Studie. Die Frage lautete,
wenn sie auf Nachrichten über News Aggregatoren, Social Media oder Suchmaschinen zugreifen,
was machen sie am häufigsten?
Antwort A, ich browse und lese die Hauptnachrichten des Tages ohne auf die Links zu klicken, um den ganzen Artikel zu,
Um auf den ganzen Artikel zuzugreifen. Antwort B, ich klicke auf die verfügbaren Links, um die ganzen Artikel auf der Originalwebsite zu lesen
Und Antwort C, ich greife nicht auf News Aggregatoren oder Social Media zu. So, jetzt haben die.
Die richtige Antwort wäre natürlich am häufigsten klicke ich natürlich nicht auf den Link, weil ich ja nur das anklicke, was mich interessiert,
Also die Frage spiegelt nicht die Realität ab. Die jemand erfährt. So, was mache ich am häufigsten? Wo ist am häufigsten? Wenn pro Besuch der Seite News Punkt Google dot com,
oder pro Link, den ich dort sehe.
Mache ich es am häufigsten, dass ich da drauf klicke, weil ja nur wenn's mich interessiert, das wäre die Antwort, ja. Wenn sie etwas interessiert, klicken sie da nicht drauf,
Das wäre und das ist ja das, was Oettinger wie wie Öttinger diese Frage interpretiert,
niemand klickt auf alle diese Links, dafür ist es, also es ist die Frage ist totaler Schluss und der rennt damit rum und,
hat sie dann auch noch falsch verstanden und die Antwort auch.
Und auch wenn diese Studie irgendwie nichts wirklich belegbar äh aussagt, zeigt sie dann trotzdem, dass einfach diese Dings einfach dann doch schon auch genutzt werden und natürlich landen die Leute dann äh da. Ich meine, wer liest sich nur,
Anreißer durch und fühlt sich informiert. Also das ist dann liest man's halt eher nicht.
Das war ich ja und da ist natürlich das Verhalten auf der ähm auf der Aggregatorenseite genauso wie überall sonst auch, ob ich jetzt, wenn ich auf News Punkt Google dot com ginge.
Oder ich gehe auf was weiß ich, Spiegel online, dann lese ich natürlich die Headlines, ja? Ich muss auch zum Beispiel zu meiner Schande gestehen, ja, dass ich nicht ein einziges Mal in meinem ganzen Leben eine Tageszeitung von vorne bis hinten durchgelesen habe,
Nee. Weißt du, was ich mache? Am häufigsten.
Du liest ja einfach nur die Anzeigen.
Lese ich nur die Werbung und kaufe die Sachen und dann werbe ich die Zeitung weg. Nein, du, ne, man liest natürlich man.
Du spielst unsere kulturelldemokratische Zukunft.
Er, den Eindruck habe ich auch.
Es ist also wirklich äh.
Ja, das ist bedrohlich, das bedrohliche ist, man bekommt wirklich den Eindruck, dass er das wirklich auch nicht versteht.
Das das der einfach so vielen Missverständnissen oder Falschdarstellungen äh erlegen ist, dass er offenbar vollkommen äh das ihm vollkommen unmöglich ist.
Hier eigentlich überhaupt irgendeinen sinnvollen Pfad einzuschlagen,
Ich meine, das Leistungsschutzrecht muss auch nochmal wachzurufen, klar. So, hat jetzt keine Auswirkung gehabt auf das,
auf die Unternehmen, die der Anlass waren offenbar, ne? Was immer so gesagt wurde, ja Google und dann irgendwie ein paar andere vielleicht auch noch. Die zahlen alle gar nichts,
aber es hat jetzt schon halt,
Deswegen viele, viele, viele Start-ups und interessante potentiell vielleicht interessante äh Ideen nicht gegeben, weil man sich natürlich einfach überhaupt nicht in so einen Bereich reintraut, der halt äh von vorne herein durch so ein beklopptes Gesetz vermient ist,
Weil man sich natürlich dann auch diese ganzen Bowswoods, die äh potentiell anstehen, äh nicht leisten,
möchte. Andererseits hat einfach auch diese dieser Interessenverband
den Medien an der Stelle einfach auch überhaupt gar keine nennenswerten Gewinne und Umsätze zu vermelden. Das meiste Geld geht hier einfach in äh juristischer Auseinandersetzung und ja am Ende verdienen nur die Anwälte.
Das ist also das Leistungsschutzrecht, das ist ja wirklich so eine ähm.
Ein Rohrgrapierer.
Ein Rohrgruppierer, ja. Gibt noch ein sehr schönes Bild im, im Rahmen dieser Berichterstattung, dass Daniel Bos gemacht hat, wo man äh Öttinger, Herrn Öttinger und Herrn Döpfner,
Vom Axel Springer-Verlag sieht, wie sie so gemeinsam ein Papier durchgehen auf diesem Kongress und Dörfner ist ja der,
diese gesamte Leistungsschutzrechtsgeschichte kommt ja.
Eigentlich war es eine Springer-Etage, ja.
Ja, was wir da gerade gehört haben, ist also wie beim wie der Bundesverband der Zeitungsverleger von einem EU-Kommissar äh aufgefordert wird, die Pressefreiheit zu missachten,
die Redaktionsfreiheit nicht direkt durch Zensur, aber schon mal durch ein durch Überzeugungen.
Ja Einschüchterung der Mitarbeiter, würde ich mal sagen.
Der Mitarbeiter,
Guck mal, wir sorgen uns doch alle um unsere demokratische kulturelldemokratische, ökonomische Zukunft, auch du willst ja das Fahrrad abbezahlen, was du finanziert hast mit deinem Lohn.
Schöne, kulturell demokratische Zukunft haben sie ja.
Wäre doch schade.
Möchte noch nicht, dass dir etwas passiert. Ja, das wäre doch. Wirklich schade. Na ja.
Das ist schon äh skurril. Ich habe übrigens heute Morgen mir einfach nochmal den den Vortrag äh tenoste War äh angehört und von Rob und.
Rob und Frank auf dem letzten Kongress.
Und äh.
Da denkt man ja dann schon auch, ne, dass was ja so sagen ist dieses, also wir haben so krasse Skandale, die wir eigentlich auch hier in dieser Sendung inzwischen,
Wöchentlich berichten und es ist wirklich nicht gegeben,
Also das irgendwie mal,
Also das ist das Level ist halt inzwischen so, ne? Ist völlig normal, dass jemand wie wie Donald Trump ernsthaft überhaupt nur in die Nähe einer einer des Hauches, einer Chance kommt, äh Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten zu werden.
Den ganzen Tag nur nur Unsinn erzählt und und Lügen und Hetze, ja.
Und Beseitigung und was nicht alles, ja.
Ein,
wirklich ihren Skandal nach dem anderen, ja. Das da, dass da, dass der EU-Kommissar gegen die gegen die Meinungsfreiheit hetzt aufm, beim Lobbyverband der Zeitungsverlänger und die applaudieren dafür. Statt dem zu sagen, dass Knall.
Das gibt schon auch ein bisschen länger. Also ich erinnere mich noch an diesen schönen äh bestimmt auch schon mal erwähnt ähm,
kriegst auch dieses Presidence Dinner, was so einmal im Jahr in USA gemacht wird, wo die ganzen versammelten Journalisten zusammenkommen.
Und wo dann ein äh ja, meistens irgendeiner so ein Comedian äh eine eine Rede hält und da auch mal ordentlich vom Leder ziehen darf, in Anwesenheit des jeweiligen äh Präsidenten,
und vor vielen Jahren als George Busch halt noch Präsident war, war es Stephen Kolber, der diese Rede gehalten hat,
kennst ja seine Rolle sozusagen so als als überzogener, konservativer, der quasi die äh Absurdität äh des konservativen Weltbildes äh einfach dadurch äh klar macht, indem er es einfach so überhöht. Äh immer wieder selber repräsentiert,
schwadroniert halt so über George David Busch, was hat für ein toller Präsident sein, denn dieser Präsident, der lässt sich nicht von Fakten ablenken,
er entscheidet einfach aus dem Bauch. Und feiert ihn dafür und so, das ist so wunderbar entlarvend. Wer das noch nicht kennt, äh ich packe das auch nochmal in die Links, das ist äh großartig. Zeitdokument.
Aber weißt du, bei den wichtigen Sachen Tim, ne? Da kann ja schon so ein Aufschrei durch die Bevölkerung echt mal so richtiges Unheil abwenden, ne? Zum Beispiel beim Roaming. Haben sie sich jetzt wieder anders überlegt.
Zum Beispiel bei Romy. Wieder anders überlegen. Echt? Ja. War jetzt doch nicht so gut. Wird's besser?
Ja, also wir wollen jetzt äh die diese zeitliche Begrenzung irgendwie wegmachen. Also gebührenfrei und ohne Zeitlimit.
Ohne zeitliche Begrenzung, kostenfreies Roaming im EU-Ausland. Das gibt's jetzt, die haben weil sie ihren Vorschlag der EU-Kommission, der wurde einfach nochmal äh ähm.
Wurde nochmal geändert, nachdem sie gesehen haben, dass sie da äh Widerstand hatten, was dieses Roaming angeht. Was ich auch echt krass finde, ich meine, die kriegen doch sehr viel mehr Widerstand für ganz andere Gesetze.
Aber jetzt hat der Anbruchsansitz in Brüssel eben gesagt, nee, machen wir jetzt so, gibt es.
Also ich weiß es jetzt nicht nicht genau, was da die treibende Kraft gewesen ist, aber wer ja von dieser Maßnahme extrem betroffen war, waren ja äh so Grenzanreiner,
Ne, also wir denken ja immer so sehr im äh Hinblick auf ähm ja
Touristen, Business Leute, die hin und her fahren, die halt mal so da sind, mal so da sind, aber tatsächlich
betrifft das Roaming ja auch Leute, die einfach ja irgendwo an der Grenze leben, das sind ja jetzt auch nicht so wenige und die dann halt so heute mal in dem Netz äh morgen mal in dem Netz landen
und ja das äh mag eine Gruppe gewesen sein, auch wenn man natürlich grundsätzlich sagen kann
bisschen Verständnis für den Ist-Zustand mag ich ja noch haben, aber langfristig sehe ich einfach überhaupt gar keine Alternative zu einem einheitlichen digitalen Markt, was ja eigentlich hier erklärt ist Ziel ist, ist das nicht auch der Titel von Herrn
Öttinger, genau diesen digitalen, mitten im Binnenmarkt herzustellen und wenn man da jetzt nicht einfach radikal rangeht und sagt, Leute, okay
Weiß ich, man hätte ja auch das schon vor einiger Zeit tun können, sagen können, so in drei Jahren läuft das einfach komplett aus, lasst euch was einfallen. Hier kriegt ihr noch ein bisschen Zeit,
Eure Businessmodelle anzupassen, aber dann gilt es ja auch für alle und ähm ja.
Öttinger sagt, das ist tatsächlich ganz interessant. Mir war gar nicht klar, oder ich hatte nicht den Verdacht, dass sie bis dahin schon öffentlich genau das Problem, was sie da haben, ähm angesprochen haben,
aber ähm bei dieser Bekanntmachung ähm wo habe ich denn jetzt hier diesen Link? Sagt er, ähm,
Was ja nicht passieren darf, ist, dass jemand.
Also ich, wir haben Unterschied, ich nehme das direkt jetzt statt. Wir haben unterschiedliche Preise in Europa,
darf nicht dazu kommen, dass sich zum Beispiel jemand eine SIM-Karte in Lettland kauft und die Karte nur in Irland benutzt, wo die Preise sechseinhalb Mal höher sei, sind als in Lettland. Das lettische Telekommunikationsunternehmen
wäre dann nach wenigen Tagen pleite, so Öttinger. Ähm.
Sind die Preise so unterschiedlich.
Ich glaube, dass er hier auch nicht ganz verstanden hat, dass äh nicht das lettische Unternehmen pleite wäre, sondern das irische, aber äh das nur am, das nur am Rande. Äh weil er möchte also diese Stabilität der Preisunterschiede.
Pflegen und die weiter behalten. Was interessant ist, weil,
Das ist ja dann kein harmonisierter Binnenmarkt und sie wollen das Problem auch weiterhin behalten. Also es ist nicht so, dass sie äh sie wollen das Problem weiterhin angehen, denn sie sagen,
Du musst schon in dem Land, wo du bist, wo du wohnst, deine SIM-Karte am meisten nutzen,
also ähm dauerhaft eine ausländische SIM-Karte zu Hause nutzen geht nicht.
Viel reisen mit einer deutschen SIM-Karte geht schon. Also mit anderen Worten, sie wollen dich einfach daran binden, dass du, wenn du in Deutschland wohnst, nur deutsche SIM-Karten dauerhaft in Deutschland einsetzt.
Ja, was ja dann letzten Endes halt einfach ein Binnenmarkt widerspricht. So, also ich meine, warum sollte denn das so sein? Also
entweder man man schafft jetzt ein ein digitalen Wettbewerb oder man lässt es bleiben so, aber das ist ja nun das erklärte Ziel, einen solchen Wettbewerb zu haben und warum sollte der dann halt ausgerechnet an diesen Grenzen äh immer wieder anderen Regeln unterliegen.
Ja in dem Fall soll der an den Grenzen unterschiedlichen Regeln widerlegen, weil diese Infrastruktur für die Netzjahr von irgendjemandem gebaut wurde. So.
Aber die nehmen ja dafür auch Gebühren für dieses Roaming, ist ja nicht so, dass die daran jetzt nicht verdienen würden.
Das ist halt die Frage. Also es soll.
Selbstverständlich ist das so. Na, wenn du jetzt.
Können sie aber also ja.
Stimmt, aber in dem Moment, die die Verordnung, wenn die Verordnung sagt, der Preis kann für den Kunden nur so und so hoch sein, dann können sich ja nicht die, also die die Mobilfunknetze,
handeln diese Roaming-Equiments miteinander aus.
Im Internet auch so ist. Äh.
Ja und den die sagen natürlich dann, okay, wir setzen für unseren Kunden einen Roaming-Preis fest
Und dann reden wir mit den einzelnen Netzen in diesem Land. Du hast auch zum Beispiel bevorzugte Roaming-Partner. Also, dass
wenn wir jetzt mit einer mit einer O2-Karte in ein bestimmtes Land fährst, dann wirst du im Zweifelsfall da, dass das nehmen, weil die wahrscheinlich das beste Roaming Egrement haben. Und deine SIM-Karte weiß dann auch, ich gehe bevorzugt zu diesem Netz.
Ne, weil es ja sein kann mit dem, mit dem anderen, mit dem Vodafone-Netz haben die halt einen schlechteren Deal als mit
mit dem mit dem vor Ort. Das heißt, die handeln die schon aus, diese Preise. Wenn jetzt aber jemand hingeht und sagt,
Ihr dürft das aber an den Kunden nicht mehr weiterreichen. Dann werden die auch die Preise, die sie untereinander sich reinwürgen, äh entsprechend anpassen.
Ja, ich denke auch, also der der Markt wird dem äh schon folgen, dass dass das aktuelle System,
dafür eben noch nicht taucht, ist ja klar. Aber zum Beispiel verstehe ich halt auch nicht, warum. Wir haben ja jetzt zum Beispiel jetzt gerade diesen schönen Fall mit äh,
der WLAN in den deutschen Zügen, ja was er nun zu Recht mehrere Jahre lang,
beklagt wurde, wie schlecht es denn funktioniert, was im Wesentlichen daran lag, dass es A von Tis Systems gemacht wurde und B ausschließlich auf dem Telekom-Netz basiert
Jetzt gibt's einen neuen Anbieter, also einen neuen Vertragspartner der Deutschen Bahn, das äh findet ja jetzt gerade äh statt
also beginnt jetzt gerade der Rollout, gibt die ersten Züge damit. Jetzt werden halt alle,
Vorhandene Netze benutzt und damit ähm hast du natürlich äh potentiell eine ganz andere Religion. Jetzt habe ich natürlich auch oft das Problem, dass ich jetzt mit meinem O zwei Mobilfunk äh Vertrag aufm Acker ähm schlechte Verbindungen haben.
Warum sollte ich denn nicht auch,
Im Telekomnetz Roaman können, warum sollte ich denn nicht auch äh äh im Vodafone-Netz äh romen können? So, das äh das ist ja das Absurde. Und äh was wahrscheinlich glaube ich auch schon ein paar Mal äh hatten, das Beispiel,
wie das ja teilweise eben auch in Schweden gehandhabt wird, dass man einfach sagt, okay, es gibt Bereiche, die sind irgendwie unterversorgt, da springt dann halt der Staat ein, ne? Also Schweden hat ja dann,
bestimmte Gebiete, wo es dann halt einfach ein Mobilfunknetz gibt, was einfach nur Sweeten heißt, in das sich einfach alle Karten einbuchen,
So und dann ist die Infrastruktur halt einfach an der Stelle eben vom Staat, weil er da eben einmal äh ein paar tausend Kilometer Glasfaser reingebuddelt hat und dann gibt's nicht dieses Rennen mit der Provider ist aber da nicht so gut und der ist da nicht so gut, sondern es gibt einfach Netz und es gibt einfach,
Frequenzen und Bandbreite und die werden einfach äh genutzt. Aber wer natürlich Infrastruktur tatsächlich baut und anderen bereitstellt, verdient ja da auch dran. Also das muss sich äh,
finden und da müssen wir hinkommen.
Ich hätte den,
Ich hätte nur tatsächlich eigentlich gedacht, dass wenn die dass die Roaming-Gebühr dann auch tatsächlich weg sind. Dass die die auch sich nicht mehr gegenseitig äh in Rechnung stellen können. Aber es stimmt natürlich, die werden das weiterhin machen.
Und da dann ist halt die Frage, also wer,
zu Ende gedacht, dann dann würde in seiner, in seinem Beispiel die das lettische Unternehmen unter Umständen tatsächlich pleite gehen, aufgrund der Roaming-Gebühren, die es in,
In Irland zahlt.
Ja, es muss halt einfach auf Basis einer ganz anderen Kalkulation arbei.
Das irische, das irische Netz hätte, aber gar gar keine Kunden mehr, würde daran pleite gehen. Also im Zweifelsfall müsstest, könntest du so etwas machen wie ähm.
Na ja, das ist halt Infrastruktur einfach da ist und von den Anbietern gemietet wird,
Ist aber in Deutschland soweit ich das richtig erinnere per Dekret nicht erlaubt. Also die die Mobilfunknetzbetreiber dürfen ähm sich Infrastruktur nicht teilen.
Ich sehe Potential, da mal einen Gast einzuladen, der sich vielleicht mit dieser Frage äh beschäftigt. Es gibt ja da auch äh erweiterten äh Umfeld ein paar neue Initiativen, da äh das alles aufzubrechen. Vielleicht äh kann man das an der Stelle auch nochmal ein bisschen genauer äh machen
Wir fassen einfach zusammen die Diskussion um Ruming ist noch nicht komplett zu Ende und äh es könnte vielleicht sogar sein,
Dass dieses ursprüngliche Doppelversprechen mit äh
Ja, wir fixen mal das Roaming und wir äh kümmern uns auch mal um die Netzneutralität, wo dann am Anfang so gedacht haben, so, oh weia, jetzt wird das eine gegen das andere ausgespielt. Ähm ja jetzt am Ende bedeutet, dass wir dann doch schon so eine ganz brauchbare praktische äh Netzneutralitätsregelung bekommen haben
und vielleicht am Ende sogar auch noch ein brauchbares Roaming, der hätte uns die Politik ja mal rundum bedient.
Mit dem äh ICE vier ist ein wichtiger Schritt zur Schiene digital getan und das ist ein äh moderner Verkehrsträger der Gigabit-Gesellschaft.
Die Gigabit-Gesellschaft. Ja, da wollte ich auch mal Mitglied werden. Gibt's da noch irgendwelche Anträge?
Geiler Verein.
Verkehrsträger der Gigabit-Gesellschaft. Ja, ich würde auch gerne die Gigabit-Gesellschaft, aber ich meine, ich habe halt einfach nicht äh die Voraussetzung, ne?
Ja? Wenn ihr hier Mitglied der Gigabit-Gesellschaft wäre, dann werden die Podcasts noch schneller on.
Bei euch Mitglied werden, so, ne.
Mhm. Ein exklusiver Club.
Ja. Hiermit beantrage ich Mitgliedschaft in der Gigabit-Gesellschaft. Ähm.
Kommen wir zur Privatsphäre.
Kommen wir zur Privatsphä.
Sichert werden.
Das Thema hatten wir, glaube ich, hier äh behandelt. Äh
Whats WhatsApps, Telefondaten und sowieso WhatsApp-Daten sollen mit den Facebookdaten vermischt werden. Schließlich hat Facebook ja neunzehn neunzehn Milliarden oder was auch immer für Facebook
Apfel für WhatsApp ausgegeben,
und ähm ich hatte auch glaube ich auch damals schon gesagt, dass mich allgemein gewundert hat, dass das noch nicht der Fall war. Ich war eigentlich davon ausgegangen und jetzt hat der,
Johannes Kasper, der Datenschutzbeauftragte Hamburgs.
Ähm Facebook verboten diese Telefonnummern von WhatsApp abzugreifen. Und äh Facebook hat gesagt.
Wer ist das? Und hat sich nicht dran gehalten. Aber jetzt ist natürlich
interessant, wie so wie geht das jetzt weiter? Das würde sehr schön äh in einem Artikel der Süddeutschen Klagestätte. Äh das ist doch eine regional zuständige Behörde. Äh wie dürfen die jetzt irgendwie so multinational operierenden Milliardenkonzernen irgendwelche
Verbote aussprechen. Da gibt es ein äh Urteil zum Recht auf Vergessenwerden des EuGH zwanzig vierzehn.
Und da steht da drin ist festgelegt für die Anwendbarkeit des Datenschutzrechts reicht es aus wenn der betroffene Konzern,
Im Geltungsbereich der maßgeblichen Vorschriften eine Niederlassung hat,
Also du hast dann dann gilt da auch dieses Datenschutzrecht. Und Facebook hat nunmal eine Niederlassung in Deutschland,
Und da ist eben der Geltungsbereich und deswegen gilt auch das deutsche Datenschutzrecht für Facebook in diesem.
Auch eine Niederlassung in Hamburg.
Das weiß ich nicht genau. Ich glaube, also ich weiß, dass sie eine in Berlin haben, aber ich weiß nicht, ob.
Weil das ist ja jetzt sehr regional, das ist ja jetzt nicht äh Deutschland.
Ja, aber der, der Kasper, okay, das ist jetzt glaube ich nochmal äh Haarspalterei, der bezieht sich ja nicht auf Hamburger Gesetze, der bezieht sich ja auf deutsche Gesetze. Ne, also.
Ja gut, aber wenn er das verbietet, also müsste das ja nicht äh Frau Vosshow eigentlich machen.
Ja, die müsste eine ganze Menge machen, aber macht's eben nicht. So, jetzt ähm.
Und jetzt ist aber noch viel interessanter. Ähm welche Grundlage will der eigentlich haben, den das zu verbiegen? Ich meine, die Daten ist ja nun mal, die Firma gehört denen ja nun mal und das sind aber ihre Daten, die können damit machen, was sie wollen,
und er sagt dieser Datentransfer.
Ist rechtswidrig nach Paragraph fünf Datenschutzgesetz, weil du eine äh wirksame Einwilligung der Nutzer brauchst und zwar eine, die im Voraus an beide Adressen gerichtet sein muss, an WhatsApp und an Facebook,
Ähm was nämlich passiert ist, du machst irgendwie WhatsApp auf und dann sagt er klick mal bitte auf,
Sonst geht's nicht weiter. Vorher konnte man immer Skip drücken, irgendwann war das Skip weg. Ähm und damit greest du gegenüber WhatsApp,
Er sagt, du müsstest auch gegenüber Facebook green und ich glaube, er meint damit nämlich genau den Aspekt ähm der genau mich betrifft, weil ich kein Facebook habe.
Na ja es ich gree, ich ich muss WhatsApp gegenüber zustimmen, dass die meine Daten an Facebook geben, habe aber keine,
kein Prozess, dass ich mit Facebook nochmal darüber rede, wie da die Datenschutzbestimmungen sind. Und deswegen sagt er, du musst das an voraus an beide Adressen richten. Das heißt, er sagt, eigentlich müsste Facebook sich über dein Facebook-Profil,
Bestätigen lassen, dass sie deine WhatsApp-Daten,
nutzen dürfen und du müsstest WhatsApp dann sagen, ja, dürft ihr machen und erst wenn's wenn du beiden gegenüber das bestätigt hast, dann kann dieser Transfer stattfinden.
Nachvollziehbar.
Denn es gibt kein Konzernprivileg, das ist den Töchtern erlaubt, Daten freihändig hin und her zu verschieben. Auch bei Übertragung innerhalb des Konzerns gilt der Datenschutz, sagt Johannes Kasper,
Ähm interessant ist auch, was was droht Facebook jetzt.
Also Facebook wird gegen diese an, hat gesagt, ja dagegen gehen wir vor, das interessiert uns nicht und sollte dann jetzt Kasper,
Recht kriegen, dann könnte er,
Eine Millionen Euro Zwangsgeld von Facebook verlangen und nachdem die neunzehn Milliarden für diese Daten ausgegeben haben könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass sie äh vielleicht einfach sagen, ja ja komm hier,
ist eine Milliarde, hier ist eine Millionen, sorry Millionen und der jetzt bitte lass uns mal hier weitermachen. Das ist ein stört einfach.
So alles. Ja, schön.
Dann war mal wieder eine Anhörung.
Bundestag.
Also genau, BND-Gesetz haben wir ja schon drüber gesprochen,
Dann gab es die äh TK Transparenzverordnung, ne? Es ist eigentlich ganz äh ganz interessant, manchmal passieren ja auch gute Dinge,
Und zwar gibt es eben eine Verordnung des der Bundesnetzagentur.
Die für Transparenz sorgen soll in ähm.
Was die Leistungsbeschreibungen von Internetprovidern angeht. Ne, also dieses bis zu so und so viel Embit-Scherze, ne? Und dann am Ende deckt sich das nicht mit deiner äh Erfahrungs.
Realität. Und da haben sie gesagt, okay, da machen wir jetzt eine Verordnung, da muss es jetzt ein Produktinformationsblatt geben und dann muss das genau drinstehen, welche Datenübertragungsraten da erreicht werden können,
Und dann machen wir, bieten wir eine Messmöglichkeit an ähm von der Bundesnetzagentur,
Oder die Provider können auch eine eigene Messmöglichkeit bereitstellen und dann kann der Nutzer sehen, ob die Leistung erbracht wird oder nicht.
Ende der Geschichte. Hm,
Die Frage ist natürlich und wir haben da äh also für den CC war dann der Alexander Lefmann da vor Ort als Sachverständiger und der CC hat auch eine Stellungnahme veröffentlicht, an der Konstanze und ich auch noch ein bisschen mitgewirkt haben,
Ähm die Frage, die sich da stellt, ist wie soll der Nutzer.
Das Nachweisen, dass die Leistung nicht erbracht wird. Und wenn er es gemacht hat.
Was soll dann passieren? Da muss doch dann wenigstens das auch flankiert werden von einem Sonderkündigungsrecht oder ähm Mietminderung oder was auch immer, ne, dass man sagt, okay, den Monat bezahle ich einfach nicht.
Nö, war zu langsam.
Weiterhin ist natürlich dieser Messprozess total unklar, ja? Also wenn der, wenn der Messprozess daraus besteht, dass auf der, auf den, auf der letzten Meile, der Provider einmal sagt, hier da sind fünfzig Mbit und die krieg ich saturiert.
Dann kann der Provider diesen Messprozess ja, dass auch dieser Begriff hinter äh gepflegt Anbieter initiierte Messung, dann kann der Provider diese Messung durchführen und er kann natürlich auch, solange diese Messung in seinem Hoheitsgebiet stattfindet,
Die problemlos manipulieren. Ja und dafür sorgen, dass die funktioniert. Es gibt ja so Fälle. Die ähm ich weiß gar nicht, ob die öffentlich so dokumentiert sind, aber.
Zum Beispiel gibt es bei dem,
Bei einem großen deutschen Anbieter für Internetzugänge, der auch ein äh Speed-Test anbietet,
Eine Verbindung dieses Speed-Tests zur Kundendatenbank, sodass der Speed-Test weiß, welches Ergebnis denn hier der Kunde wohl erwartet.
Ein Schäm, wer Böses dabei denkt.
Wenn dann die eigene Software auf einmal die Daten liefert, wie es wohlwahrscheinlich ist, also das hatten wir doch bei Volkswagen irgendwie, du war noch nichts hast.
Genau. So.
Mhm.
Willst du testen? Alles gut. Guck mal hier, äh fünfzig Mittaun, aber gemessen. So und du kannst selber sehen, dass du diese, dass du diese Bandbreite gar nicht erreichst, ne? Also so,
Also das ist natürlich naheliegend, dass solche Tests ähm.
Ja, so ein bisschen so auch so ein bisschen so Wahlcomputer äh Realität. Ja, nee, ihre Stimme wurde gezählt. Hier steht ja auf dem Bildschirm.
Genau, so, also das gibt diesen dieses
Dieses Problem gibt es, das heißt, du möchtest eine unabhängige Messung haben. Und da wird's natürlich jetzt interessant, weil also auf der, auf der letzten Meile, solange du im Hochheitsgebiet des Anbieters bist, kann er dir diese Leistung natürlich immer erbringen. Aber wie machst du jetzt die Messung.
Mal realistisch,
Ja, also es kann ja super sein. Vielleicht hast du ja sogar einen Gigabit nach Hause liegen. Der Anbieter selber hat ja aber ähm seine äh Peering Equiments.
Die dich so und so in die in die Welt verbinden. Und natürlich sagt er dir garantiert er dir nicht, dass du fünfzig Mbit in,
überall auf der Welt hinkriegst. Es kann ja auch sein, dass eben unterwegs du mit etwas redest, was gar nicht so schnell sprechen kann.
Aber.
Oder zum Beispiel äh zu bestimmten Zeiten seine Anbindung zu YouTube schlecht ist nicht ausreichend ist, um den Bedarf der Kunden zu decken und dann YouTube ruckelt. Und dann sagt der Anbieter, der deine fünfzig Mit kriegst du. Nur halt nicht,
nur nicht dahin, wo du sie haben willst, weil da habe ich äh zu schlechte Kapazitäten gebucht. Das heißt, dieser Messprozess ist alles andere als trivial
Und das eigentlich äh das eigentlich das Einzige, glaube ich, was ein sinnvoller, eine sinnvolle Messung wäre, die fair wäre, ist ähm,
Weil dann hast du IP-Adressen und Ports, die von überall auf der Welt Random sind,
Wo vielleicht mal von dem einen was schnell ist, von dem anderen was Langsames kommt. Du kriegst aber die Leitung saturiert. Das wäre ein fairer,
Messprozess und ich fänd's gar nicht schlecht, wenn die Anbieter auf diesen Messprozess äh ihre Netze optimieren würden, um sicherzustellen, dass beim Torent auch wirklich die Bandbreite erreicht,
Das machen die nämlich, da gab's einen sehr schönen Fall. Kürzlich ich weiß gar nicht mehr in welchem Land das war. Ähm da gibt's ein ich glaube das war Team Mobile. Die Mobile verteilt da SIM-Karten.
Und äh so Prepaids im Karten und wenn du die Anmasse an, gehst rein, dass sie hier, ich will ins Netz, ne? Und dann kommt, wirst du umgeleitet auf eine andere Seite und dann steht da hier, sie haben kein Guthaben,
Wenn aber in der URL, die du aufrufst, das Wort äh Speed-Test vorkam, dann kamst du dorthin.
Und äh ohne jegliche Einschränkung. Das heißt, die hatten quasi ihr gesamtes Scheiß Online-Rooting darauf manipuliert, dass alle Beschränkungen wegfallen, sobald irgendwo Speed-Test steht.
Was sehr, sehr, sehr shady ist schon mal
zu Beginn with. In dem Fall aber ganz lustig war, weil der junge Mann, der das entdeckt hat, hat sich dann halt ein ähm ein Proxi gebaut, der unter's äh seine Domains Schrägstrich Speed-Test erreichbar war und hatte dann
kostenfreie, unbegrenzte Daten, weil er ja nicht bezahlen musste, weil er da, weil er es mit einer noch nicht mit Datenguthaben versorgten SIM-Karte machen konnte.
Finde ich sehr, finde ich natürlich sehr schön, aber es zeigt natürlich auch, dass die aktiv,
Diese Messprozesse versuchen zu begünstigen. Und da Ausnahmeregeln zu haben und dich ansonsten irgendwie hin und her shapen und drosseln wie sie es witzig finden. Aber sobald sie sehen, oh Scheiße, will uns einer messen, ja? Und das ist exakt,
VW Style. Das ist exakt 4W-Style. Deswegen brauchst du.
Wagining nennt man das.
Genau, deswegen brauchst du hier halt einen klar definierten Messprozess, der für alle gleich sein muss und dann eben auch äh vor allem unabhängig durchgeführt wird.
Zum Beispiel von deiner Fritzbox.
Ja, also wie auch immer, ne? Also da kann man viel machen, aber den der in dieser Verordnung ist, der Messprozess eben nicht,
Erklärt nicht detailliert und äh das haben wir hier hm gefordert.
Ansonsten war das eine Anhörung. Ich mein natürlich ist das erstmal gut, Verbraucherrechte im Telekommunikationsmarkt zu stärken. Das versuchen die hier mit dieser Anordnung, aber sie riecht halt schon wieder so ein bisschen nach ähm,
da passiert nix, ne? Da da wird dann wieder kein Hebel drangesetzt. Das heißt, die müssen, die machen jetzt ihre Produktinformationsblätter wunderbar
gibt auch noch andere schöne Aspekte, die ich also die Verordnung ist nicht so schlecht, ja? Steht auch zum Beispiel drin, auf jeder Rechnung muss muss das nächste Kündigungsdatum drin stehen. Und
davon abgezogen, die Frist bist, wann du wirklich kündigen musst. So, ne, damit du einfach mal weißt, äh, dass du quasi mit jeder Rechnung davor gewarnt wirst, wann
die automatische Vertragsverlängerung zuschlägt und dich zu einem noch unglücklichen unglücklicheren Menschen für einen noch längeren Zeit,
Würde er für einen noch längeren Zeitraum machen. Also da gibt's schon mal eine ganz gute ganz gute Hebel in dieser in dieser Transparenzverordnung und ähm Alexander Lefman hat eben noch ein paar Verbesserungsvorschläge äh gemacht aus seiner,
technisch fundierten Perspektive darüber, was eben wie eben das Internet tatsächlich funktioniert.
Dann äh ein weiterer Aspekt äh der Bundesnetzagentur ähm.
Die müssen sich ja jetzt auch Gedanken darüber machen, wie das mit dem Vorratsdatenspeichern funktionieren soll. Und da gab es dann eine Beschwerde äh der kleineren Anbieter,
Die sagten ja ähm,
Das Problem mit diesen Vorratsdatenspeichern ist ja, dass das unsere Verbandsmitglieder äh total belasten kann. Das ist ja sehr teuer mit diesen Vorortsdaten und so, ne? Waren die
Telekommunikationsverbände, Breko Bugglas und VATM gesagt, wir müssen das ähm,
Wir müssen ihn nachbessern, dass man die wir wollen nämlich diesen Betrieb dieses Vorratsdatenspeicherungssystemes outforcen dürfen, weil es,
zu teuer und zu komplex sein kann das Innenhaus umzusetzen.
Die Bundesnetzagentur hat nämlich auch relativ ausführliche technische ähm,
Rahmenbedingungen dafür definiert, ne? Also kannst du nicht einfach da haben sie schon eben wieder irgendwie so ein Consultant hingesetzt, der hat da geschickt, Datentransport nur verschlüsselt,
Daten in Transit müssen immer verschlüsselt sein. So, ja gut, das musste leider tatsächlich in sowas reinschreiben, sonst schicken die irgendwelche UDP-Pakete ans andere Ende der Welt. Ähm und jetzt wird eben gesagt, okay,
Man kann es Outsourcen. Und dann hast du dann wird sich bestimmt wieder dieses israelische Unternehmen melden,
die das schon für unsere Telefonrechnungen machen und wird sagen, passt auf, ist gar kein Problem. Gar kein Problem, eure Vorratsdatenspeicherung könnt ihr locker zu uns Outsourcen. Wir machen das auch sehr viel günstiger,
Wir machen einen fairen Preis für die kleinen Betreiber.
VDS A ist Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist es Service. Worauf läuft sie da aus, ne?
Dass Ionosphäreninstitut steht schon bereit und freut sich auf die Ausschreibung.
Wir lösen das alles im Weltall.
Stimmt.
Kommt dann Weltraum rechts zum Einsatz und so und deswegen ist das auch total unproblematisch. Ja, die Weltraumtheorie ist für einiges gut.
Ja äh dann hatten wir glaube ich schon darüber gesprochen, dass ähm Chelsea Menning ja für ihren äh Suizidversuch bestraft werden muss. Ja, so geht das ja nicht, könnte könnte ja jeder kommen.
Ja, aber gucken wir denn dahin, wenn die Leute sich einfach das Leben nehmen und sich irgendwie einen Zugriff entziehen.
Genau, so haben wir ja nicht gewettet, meine Liebe und deswegen
Weil sie ja unter der äh Isolationshaft mit den Haftbedingungen so sehr gelitten hat, dass es sie in an die Grenzen zum Suizid getrieben hat, kriegt sie jetzt als Strafe.
Nochmal das Gleiche.
Vierzehn Tage äh Isolationshaft. Ähm wovon sie aber erstmal nur ähm.
Sieben absitzen muss, weil die restlichen sieben äh suspendiert sind. Das heißt, die könnte man dann einfach jederzeit äh,
Abfeiern, ne? Weißt du, wenn sie ihnen gerade nicht gefällt, wenn sie gerade wieder im Guardian eine Frechheit geschrieben hat, dann holt man mal so, ach guck mal, wir haben hier noch, wir haben noch sieben Tage Isolationshaftguthaben bei dir. Äh die machen wir jetzt mal eben kurz klar.
Ja also da fällt einem irgendwie auch nichts mehr zu ein. Das ist äh,
Also der Umgang mit ich sage mal politischen Gefangenen äh ist ohnehin schon sehr äh fragwürdig. Also auch schon der Umgang mit Gefangenen an sich das gesamte Präsent System in den USA ist äh,
für meinen Geschmack einfach einerseits hochkorrupt und andererseits einfach durch durch eine Privatisierung auch in so eine Dynamik geraten, äh die gar nicht mehr gut ist,
Aber hier ist es halt ähm einfach,
einfach eine eine betonte Gnadenlosigkeit, die in irgendeiner Form versucht, eine Härte durchzusetzen, die am Ende aber genau das Gegenteil erreicht,
also Guantanamo dürfte wahrscheinlich auch sehr viel mehr Terroristen hervorgebracht haben, als sie dort äh auch nur irgendwie interniert haben und das äh ist einfach nicht gut, aber das merkt dieses Land irgendwie nicht.
Aber es gibt ja auch gute Nachrichten. Es gibt ja äh diese Geburtstage. Wir haben da demnächst einen,
dieses Jahr wenn wir in dieser Sendung jetzt keine weiteren.
Spoil Wispoilern.
Boilern erstmal noch äh äh nix. Gibt da sozusagen jetzt im Vergleich zur letzten Woche keine nennenswerten Neuigkeiten zu verkünden,
Aber es gibt auch noch andere Organisationen, die seit fünf Jahren existieren und die eine steht uns auch so halbwegs nahe. Haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal drüber berichtet, hatten wir auch schon Initiator hier zu Gast,
einmal, zweimal, ich glaub Interview hatten wir auch Kongress mal gemacht vor längerer Zeit.
Ich glaube, der hat ja das, das war vielleicht sogar der Kongress, wo er, wo das überhaupt vorgestellt wurde, ja.
Startet es, ne? Ja, ich glaube, dann zu Beginn, ich schlage mal nach. Es geht um frag den Start.
Die haben fünf, fünf, fünfjähriges Bestehen gefeiert, gab's eine kleine ähm Veranstaltung in in Berlin kurzfristig mit relativ wenigen Gästen. Ähm.
Wo dann auch glaube ich wieder viel äh André Meister ist, unser bester Kunde. Der facht ja den ganzen Tag, hat ja lange Zeit äh nix anderes gemacht, als einfach nur IFG Anfragen geschrieben. Und äh gibt eine sehr schöne ähm.
Fundraising-Kampagne kann man da eigentlich sagen äh und zwar verkaufen sie die Edition null null null null null null. Ähm,
ein geschwärztes Blatt Papier. Was sie im Rahmen einer Informations äh Freiheitsanfrage äh bekommen haben.
Ähm hier als Kunstdruck gerahmt kann man das da kaufen und bekommt da äh ich glaube,
Eine Fördermitgliedschaft oder so kostet das,
Äh kann man erstehen unter dem unter der schönen Domain null null null null null null,
Punkt limited und da sind dann diese Kunstdrucke eben abgebildet. Das ist ein ach Heli.
Das ist ein GK-Druck gerahmt, handgefaltet und handgelocht. Zwanzig mal dreißig Zentimeter,
die man da, den man da erstehen kann.
Nummeriert, ne?
Da ist doch mal eine Idee. Wir können ja auch mal hier unsere unsere Shownotes.
Da gucken jetzt die dreiundzwanzig.
Goldrahmen ausliefern.
Ja, das äh das kann man also, da kann man sich was Schönes für die Wand kaufen. So sieht Pressefreiheit zwanzigsechzehn aus. Informationsfreiheit zwanzig sechzehn. Herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag und auf viele weitere Jahre.
Letztes Mal haben wir dann irgendwie angefangen, Chaostreffs zu äh verkünden. Das führt natürlich jetzt unweigerlich zur Kampagne. So soll es sein.
Soll es sein? Ja, ist ja super, also gründet schwärmen sie aus, gründen sie Chaostreffs.
Überzeugen sie die analogen Bürger, die haben teilweise noch andere Ansichten.
Kämpfen sie um ihre kulturelldemokratische Zukunft
Äh der Chaostreff Willingen-Schwenningen ist Treffpunkt für alle Chaosnahen aus dem Raum Schwarzwald Bar.
Hackerspace, wie Space One angeschlossen. Jeden Dienstag ab neunzehn Uhr gibt es da öffentliche Treffen zur Wissen, Wissensförderung in der,
Wilhelm Binderstraße neunzehn in Willingen, dort gibt es gemütliche Plätze, coole Atmosphäre und Mate. Viel mehr braucht man ja auch gar nicht. Also wer in Willingen, Schwenningen gestrandet ist, kann jetzt
in den Space One gehen. Zum Chaostreff. Ist doch super. Wir freuen uns.
Das bringt uns als Ende der Sendung.
Ja
Dann doch hier durchgeackert. Es war jetzt ein bisschen mehr Themen, aber.
Ja, ich äh Themen kommen jeden jeden Tag neue Themen.
Krass, oder? Na ja, das ist meine neue Themen, das sind eine sehr gedehnte äh Variante von neu.
Neue News. Ich klicke übrigens siebenundvierzig Prozent der äh der Artikel klicke ich. Wir könnten auch mal machen. Äh.
Nur so, Frechheit.
Ich äh bei den Werbeanzeigen klicke ich hundert Prozent, ich kaufe das auch alles.
Ach so. Ja, jetzt auch. So sind wir.
Habe ich in letzter Zeit irgendwas gekauft? Ja, ich habe was gekauft.
Hast was gekauft? Ja, uns wurde auch äh das ein oder andere gekauft.
Ja, deswegen danken wir danke ich dem Tobias.
Genau und ich wie immer allen anderen,
Die Dockboten Netzpolitik und die Mieterebene äh unterstützen. Ja und ansonsten wünschen wir euch noch frohen Cyber ähm ne. Äh ist ja auch äh immer wieder da und äh dann hören wir uns nächste Woche.
Ciao ciao.